zum tagesgespräch bei phoenix begrüße
ich ganz herzlich dietmar bartsch von
der fraktion die linke im bundestag
größe ganz herzlich guten morgen
begrüßte sie auch dass herr söder jetzt
vorprescht und sich impfstoff beschafft
das ist ja nicht unbedingt ein bild von
einigkeit und von gemeinsamen handelns
in deutschland finden sie das gut
nein wir erleben derzeit chaostage
insbesondere in der union ich bin ja
sehr dafür dass man auch den impfstoff
sputnik you wenn er denn da es nutzt das
wäre dringend notwendig und ich hätte
mir da mehr anstrengungen seitens der
bundesregierung gewünscht das ist nun
herrn söder treibt dort besonders aktiv
zu werden
das kann nicht aus der sicht der kür des
kanzlerkandidaten vielleicht verstehen
aber nicht aus einer sachlichen sicht
das was derzeit stattfindet ist
unverantwortlich
noch vor drei tagen hieß es brücken
lockdown und vor allen dingen vorziehen
der ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
jetzt soll sie nach hinten verschoben
werden ich würde mir wünschen dass in
der union endlich klarheit einzieht und
im übrigen ist dort die kanzlerin
zuallererst gefordert also das heißt die
kanzlerin braucht mehr macht oder es
geht nicht darum mehr macht wissen sie
wenn es so einfach wäre
die kanzlerin entscheidet und die
pandemie wer besiegt denn wir ja alles
gut dann würde ich sagen ja aber das ist
nicht der fall
ich fordere dass die entscheidung da
wieder zurück gebracht werden wo sie
hingehören nämlich in den deutschen
bundestag und den bundesrat die
kanzlerin muss eine regierungserklärung
im deutschen bundestag halten
das erwarte ich wo sie ihre strategie
darlegt denn wir sehen ja dass im moment
kritisiert wird jeden tag wird eine neue
sau durchs dorf getrieben und die
verunsicherung bei den menschen die wird
größer unser wichtigstes gut ist es
vertrauen in die maßnahmen und das wird
immer mehr erschüttert und wir sehen
auch dass viele menschen nicht mehr
können deshalb brauche es klarheit und
da ist über alles zu reden wegen meiner
auch über veränderungen des
infektionsschutzgesetzes das ist
überhaupt nicht meine frage aber ich
möchte nicht abstrakt
drüber reden sondern konkret nicht jeden
tag eine neue vokabel sondern klare
vorgaben diskussionen und dann
entscheidungen und zuletzt ja ich
wünsche mir dass es ein breiteres
einbeziehen gibt von virologen jahr von
intensivmediziner aber bitte auch von
pädagogen von psychologen von juristen
von wirtschaftswissenschaftlern damit
wir klarer in die zukunft sehen können
also sie sagen das
infektionsschutzgesetz sollte ruhig
geändert werden entweder die richtung
denn also mehr kompetenzen beim bund
mehr kompetenzen beim bund helfen uns
nicht unbedingt der bund sollte zunächst
mal die möglichkeiten die er mit dem
infektionsschutzgesetz hat ausschöpfen
und wir haben doch ein ganz zentrales
problem dass es im problem
deswegen sollten wir auch dafür sorgen
dass mehr produziert wird da müssen mehr
druck entstehen wird immer gesagt es ist
schnell nicht möglich der entschuldigung
diese forderung wurde schon im
vergangenen jahr gestellt
es ging bei der zulassung von bayern
takt zu recht kurz vor weihnachten sehr
schnell
jetzt braucht es ewig bei der zulassung
von sputnik view bei der ema ich kann
das alles nur begrenzt nachvollziehen
deswegen mögen die zuständigen
arbeitskreise ersparen herr ganz kurz
dann ist doch er sei auf dem richtigen
weg müssten sie doch gut verstehen oder
vielleicht rufen sie mal bei den
russischen freunden an
aber wissen sie ich rede nicht so viel
darüber herr söder hat angekündigt hat
er denn schon eine impf dosen ein
er redet viel und er macht das mit blick
auf die kanzlerkandidatur
das nervt mich unendlich ein sehr
hilfreicher beitrag wäre wenn es in der
union dort endlich eine entscheidung
geben würde und nicht diese profilierung
sucht das agieren in der pandemie
bestimmen würde ich habe überhaupt
nichts dagegen ich bin sogar dafür dass
man diesen impfstoff nach deutschland
bringt das damit vermisst wird endlich
zügig nur zu aber wichtigtuerei personal
hat keine einzige dose aber er redet
darüber dass er vor verträge macht ich
finde dass das nicht gut ist ich bin
dafür dass der impfstoff nach
deutschland kommt wenn dafür dass die
verantwortlichen ihre aufgaben
wahrnehmen aber ich bin nicht dafür dass
profilierungssucht vorn steht sind sie
grundsätzlich für das was wir als
flickenteppich beschrieben wird dass
also die bundesländer entscheiden so wie
manche ministerpräsidentin
ministerpräsidenten sagen wir haben
niedrige instanzen in bestimmten
gebieten
da können wir ein bisschen lockern wir
haben höhere instanzen dort und dort da
müssen wir ein bisschen nachjustieren
sind sie dafür oder sagen sie nee wenn
dann sollte es doch bundeseinheitlich
sein weil immer dieser ruf nach dieser
bundes einheitlichkeit kommt ich bin
dafür dass es bundeseinheitliche
rahmenbedingungen gibt das gibt es im
übrigen schon jetzt es ist nur so es
werden beschlüsse gefasst und danach
macht jeder seins ich kann in
mecklenburg vorpommern in meiner heimat
in vorpommern nicht erklären wo wir
instanzen haben die teilweise unter 50
liegen wir haben städte wo überhaupt
niemand infiziert es ist trotzdem werden
die schulen zu gemacht das ist schwer
erklärbar
ich bin gegen einen flickenteppich für
einheitliche rahmenbedingungen aber dann
bitte möge entschieden werden denn wenn
es denn so wäre wir hätten einen lock
down und danach wäre alles gut dann wäre
ich sofort dafür für den härtesten job
der welt aber wir brauchen eine
perspektive niemand glaubt doch
ernsthaft dass danach die pandemie etwa
erledigt wäre nein das ist nicht der
fall
pandemie heißt weltweit wir müssen
andere anstrengungen unternehmen und wir
müssen bitte und das wiederhole ich wir
müssen bitte die kompetenz derjenigen
die sich auf ihren feldern auskennen
bündeln wir sind derzeit in einer
chaotischen situation wir haben einen
riesen kommunikationsproblem seitens der
bundesregierung niemand weiß mehr was
für regelungen real gelten und das muss
beendet werden und deshalb fordere ich
noch mal zurück da wo es hingehört
demokratische entscheidungen werden von
den legitimierten abgeordneten des
deutschen bundestages getroffen da mögen
die kanzlerin ihre vorstellungen
darlegen und sie hat ja mehrheiten in
der koalition ich sehe nur der zeit dass
viele einzelne den versuch machen blick
auf den wahlkampf sich zu profilieren
dietmar artig danke ihnen ganz herzlich
für das gespräch viele grüße und bleiben
sie gesund wurde gleichfalls